So as I’ve stated in the problem, some of these are
subjective, but here is my answer. I believe that the most
severe threat is if Alice’s onion proxy is compromised.
if an attacker has access to Alice’s onion proxy,
if Alice’s onion proxy is compromised, an attacker can learn
all of Alice’s traffic. The least severe threat is option A.
If an attacker in the middle intercepts the Relay Extend
request between onion router 2 and onion router 3,
in attempts to set up a different Diffie-Hellman key,
the hash check will detect problem. And so I think
this is the least threatening between E and F, I think that
E is more threatening than F having control of the entry
and exit nodes is more powerful than having control of
this just the entry and some node in the middle.
And so now we need to figure out where to put D and B.
I think that D is a weaker threat than F just being able to
observe network traffic is not very useful if you cannot
correlate anything. Having control of two routers will give an
attacker some ability to correlate traffic perhaps through
timing attacks. So D is a weaker attack than F. I think that B
is a more threat than E. If an attacker controls the directory
server, it could possibly return only nodes under its control.
Then having control of three nodes is a more serious threat
than having control only two nodes
So my answer is C, B, E, F, D and A.